what do you make of daniel dennett's
explaining consciousness
or consciousness explained
well i i think it's a perfect um
expression a very intelligent expression
of a certain
kind of take on the world of valdan
which
is to use the term that you invoked at
the beginning of our talk uh that is
i think
rather sadly impoverished
and it's not a thing that can easily be
solved by argument these are things that
you come to
through experience
in other words they involve canon as
well as vissen
and
they come out of the fruit of many kinds
of attention to the world
not just the claim that comes from
arguing in a seminar room
and so i not not there's anything wrong
with doing that but again it's a
supplementary aspect of what philosophy
is
philosophy has got a little bit lost i
think as a sort of technical department
in the university
somewhere somewhat like engineering and
interestingly dan dennett says that if
he hadn't been a philosopher he probably
been an engineer
um which which seems to be intuitively
right
um
but it also
points to perhaps a certain
i don't know
unwillingness to accept that things
might be beyond what he knows and more
complex
it's interesting that engineers for
example have a very high i did a study
on this at
the mortally hospital which i've never
actually got around to publishing but it
was very clear that i didn't expect the
results that people who became mentally
ill
at university
uh with a major mental illness
those who became manic depressive i had
an emotional disturbance
as a primary element in their psychosis
were not principally philosophers or
engineers but those with schizophrenia
were massively more likely to have been
studying engineering or philosophy than
any other subject
and
it's also come to light that
terrorists who are fundamentalists
have
engineers i'm more represented amongst
them than amongst other people
i i you know of course i'm not i'm not
trying to say that
that all engineers are like this but i'm
just pointing to a sort of certain kind
of
i don't know
the predilection for engineer like
thinking is what
is also so it's a predilection for for
categorical thinking and for
a lack of willingness to accept that
things
are not certain and maybe much more
complex than one has given them credit
for being